after the terrible news of Kobe's death
and seeing Shaq's reaction of trying to
mend relationships it makes me think of
my past friendship with my buddy Ryan we
were best friends through middle school
I would go to his place just about every
weekend to play Halo eat hot pockets and
text girls on his sidekick phone but
during high school I feel like he
ditched me to become best friends with
our mutual friend eh
I was hurt by that but since we're still
friends I didn't make a fuss of it also
during high school he got into a
relationship with a girl that he's still
with we're 25 now needless to say we've
grown apart and I see him he still feels
resentment about that and it haunts me
what would you guys do in my position
should I reach out shower everything's
fine I'm from the streets I'm sorry I
just worry for comfort everything's fine
he's gonna slip off his chair what the
guy's saying I have a friend like that
too I have a friend named Jenson I'll
say it he said I love him and I don't
know what it is but we just kind of
drifted apart mm-hmm and you know when
something like kobe thing happens i
think of him a lot and i I want to be
able to like to sit down with them and
just have a meal but I don't know why I
haven't reached out you know I mean it's
I don't know what it is but don't you
think that if you if you were someone
else like you would always tell yourself
to do it like if you put yourself as
you'd be like to [ __ ] sake Bobby
[ __ ] sake Bobby life is too short you
could get that's exactly and also I have
a question do you still enjoy his
company
you can't obligate yourself yeah you
just grown apart I'm gonna see something
so Hollywood in douchey and this is
something that I'm gonna say it is um
over the years it sounds so bad and
we're not I don't know I'm
gonna say because your fame no it's not
even just that it's just that I've
always surrounded myself with dudes that
are just funnier than me right up my
game
so you know everyone that I've
surrounded myself with or people that
are you know there are big comics that
are really super funny and not morally
Bank some morally bankrupt but yeah but
but mostly good good people and I hate
that about myself you know my hate the
it's not that I feel like a star [ __ ]
no I decided about that it's just
because there's a lot of people that are
big that I hate and I don't want to hang
out I think I think in some ways that's
sort of aspirational you want to be like
challenged you want to you want to be
around people that are sort of
like-minded I don't think I'm feel like
sometimes people hold on to [ __ ] because
they they they they want to encumber
themselves with something and it's like
they're used to that place of having
some kind of weight on them you know
like we get used to having that and
carrying that around with us and
sometimes the weight is more important
in the actual relationship yeah skip the
[ __ ] over it and say hi or send that
text you and you're all of a sudden
that's gone and you either have a
relationship where you don't you know I
already know that that's gonna happen
also I have to say this is this that I
love him right
like if he passed it would be
devastating to me right you know and I
think I think that's your answer
all right no no let's go back to now
this coulomb [ __ ] column you guys
sure anyone in your life you didn't
reach out to and you finally did or wish
you could right now are you guys just
perfect people
no I speak for myself no I keep the
people I know have no I'm crap book
correspondence but I'm lucky I'm pretty
crappy [ __ ] I've been here for like
eight months like I've there's so many
babies I haven't met
I'm so far from home I mean I feel like
I'm living on the moon I might as well
be I dated him in the last seven years
because I think that he's so funny
that when I have to sit through
[Music]
conversing with very unfunny people